hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's pizza und zwar ein rezept
ich mache pizza calzone das ist die
zusammengeklappte pizza die ihr
vielleicht auch vom italiener kennt und
ursprünglich wurde diese pizza immer in
heißem fett frittiert oder ausgebacken
wird heute nervös oder auch noch so
gemacht aber ich werde sie heute in
einem backofen zubereiten und den
meisten kriterien ist es üblich dass sie
einfach im steinofen gebacken wird also
hier in deutschland glaube ich kaum noch
einer
es gibt aber auch versionen wurde pizza
calzone einfach etwas kleiner zubereitet
wird und tatsächlich noch frittiert wird
aber das sparen wir uns heute um werden
die ganz lecker aus einem ofen zu
bereiten dafür stelle ich jetzt meinen
basis pizzateig her
den werde ich mal schnell vorbereiten
für den teig traurig 900 gramm mehl ein
päckchen trockenhefe oder einen halben
würfel hefe zwei esslöffel zucker zwei
teelöffel salz sechs esslöffel olivenöl
und 500 milliliter warmes wasser ich
werde jetzt einfach alle zutaten
zusammen kneten
da werde ich jetzt auch keine fahrt
herstellen und ihr könnt wie gesagt
frische hefe oder trockenhefe nehmen
aber ich habe keine frische deswegen
gibt es heute trockenhefe und das könnte
jetzt entweder mit den händen machen
oder einfach mit der küchenmaschine
jetzt gleich alles rein also alle
zutaten
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr die trockenen
zutaten fordern dass kurz berühren dann
verteilt sich alles etwas schneller
und jetzt kommt noch das wasser mit rein
um zum schluss auch das fett und der
hefeteig sollte jetzt etwa sieben bis
acht minuten blick nähte werden damit er
schön elastisch wird
der teig gesetzt gut durch getötet und
ich habe die küchenmaschine auch auf
etwa 40 grad gestellt das heißt falls
eine küchenmaschine mit
temperaturanzeige habt könnt ihr das
machen dann geht der teig später einfach
mit der schneller auf und von der
konsistenz her ist es schön geschmeidig
aber nicht soweit nicht schön und
erklärt vor allem auch nicht mehr
und jetzt teile ich ihnen bereits in
vier gleich große portionen ein und
lassen dann erst ausgehen einmal
halbieren und dann nochmal halbieren
diese form ich jetzt zur ubs
jetzt nämlich ein backblech only keine
back folie drauf und wenn es detail
kugeln jeweils mit olivenöl einstreichen
und sie dann abgedeckt für etwa eine
halbe stunde aufgehen lassen
der hefeteig geht jetzt gerade noch auf
und hier kocht übrigens geraten das
super für samira und für ella
wahrscheinlich gleich davon kindergarten
und ich werde euch jetzt schon mal die
zutaten für die füllung zeigen und zwar
wird es jetzt keine traditionell
original italienische canzone sondern
eine leicht orientalisch ist ohne genau
mittig und mit einem anderen käser sieg
ein
mozzarella sondern ein café keese denn
der charaktere ist bei uns sieht
ziemlich belebt ja ich es dann nicht gab
es keine karlsruhe ist eine kühl sony
oder hölzerne wird kurz eine szene also
hinaus also sozusagen eine getötete er
irgendwie möglich spanisches rezept also
grad ich zeige euch mal kurz die zutaten
für die füllung traurig eine gelbe und
rote paprika 200 g cocktailtomaten 200 g
champignons fünf bis sechs scharfe
peperoni 250 g ricotta käse ein bis zwei
knoblauchzehen jeweils einen teelöffel
getrockneten oregano und basilikum eine
fixe killy 250 gramm stück des bereits
in scheiben geschnitten und 400 gramm
verscharrt käse ich nehme jetzt zuerst
einmal den käse und das zuvor switches
zutaten sagen wie viel die zutaten nicht
genau also na klar gemüse und so weiter
ist alles klar
ricotta käse bekommt ihr wirklich in
jedem supermarkt die traditionelle
calzone wird auch mit rekordhitze
gemacht ihr könnt sie aber wenn ihr
wollt natürlich auch mit einer
tomatensoße machen aber so bisher
traditionell wollte jetzt schon bleiben
dann zu dem shooter klassiker die
türkische knoblauch wurst die demo hat
super gerne ist und die kaufen wir auch
bereits in scheiben geschnitten
also muss ich sagen dass mir jemals
gelebt hat wenn man
manche probieren so ungefähr und zwar
ist diese gelbe verpackung und das ist
auch die die uns am besten eigentlich
die verpackung unserer wie schon fertig
geschnitten uns ja auch als ganzes stück
genau 30 jahren unterschieden ja ob ihr
sitz fertig geschnitten oder am ganzen
im ganzen stück kauft macht wirklich
keinen unterschied und ich verwende wie
gesagt statt mozzarella diesen gase
kascha käse und zwar ist es in
schnittkäse der eine ganz tolle schmelz
eigenschaft hat und den benutzten wir
zum beispiel gerne für soukup post also
für post mit butter und käse
da passt perfekt dazu und ich bekomme
hier wie bundestrainer logos das
bekommen wir alles im globus am tisch
ein großer supermarkt ansonsten gibt's
die sache natürlich auch einen
türkischen genau so ich werde jetzt erst
einmal die stop wurst so grob schneiden
wahrscheinlich jetzt stoße lieber am
stück ich finde dass man sie so besser
platzieren können
wenn ihr könnt natürlich auch salami
nehmen oder zum beispiel putin schinken
oder das ganze natürlich auch
vegetarisch machen oder auch passt
die champignons zeit ist jetzt
entscheiden
die paprika werde ich jetzt in scheiben
schneiden und da gibt es dann einfach
ein trick um so wenig wie möglich zu
produzieren und zwar drückt ihr hier den
stängel 1
man könnt ihr sie jetzt halbieren und
daneben schneiden
das gemüse habe ich jetzt geschnitten
die peperoni habe ich jetzt in den extra
gefäß denn die sind wirklich ein
bisschen schlaf und die mache ich jetzt
nicht überall rein
jetzt werde ich den rekord käse würzen
und zwar kommen da ist die zwei kleinen
knoblauchzehen rein und auch die größe
und die knoblauchzehen reibe ich jetzt
ein
den käse wird sich jetzt noch mit etwas
salz und pfeffer
und dann müssen wir noch durchgeführt
werden
der kav käse werden fein gerieben
jetzt habe ich alles vorbereitet und die
teilchen auch gut aufgegangen und jetzt
nehmen die etwas mehl auf die
arbeitsfläche und jetzt nehmen die einen
teig und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch
vorher schon portioniert man so ein
bisschen einfacher geht und den öffnete
jetzt mit den händen auf 30 zentimeter
größe natürlich könnt ihr hier auch ein
aufbaustab nehmen aber mit den händen
geht es auch ganz einfach
jetzt kommt die füllung rein und zwar
kommt als erstes etwas ricotta auf die
eine hälfte
und jetzt kommt noch die restliche
füllung mit rein
jetzt könnt ihr natürlich nehmen was ihr
möchtet ich nehme es die zutaten die ich
vorbereitet habe und gebe es von allem
ein bisschen aus mit rein
und jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen käse
mit rein detzer läuft dann nämlich im
inneren so richtig lecker jetzt nur
aufpassen dass der rand schön frei
bleibt
jetzt wird die freie hälfte also die
lehre hälfte darüber geklappt und
calzone heißt wörtlich übersetzt
übrigens rose ich denke einfach mal das
eben zugeklappt wird man sieht eben
nicht was drinnen steckt jetzt am rand
gut fest drücken
und wer möchte kann jetzt beispielsweise
noch den rand ein bisschen verschönern
und zwar hier außen einfach eindrücken
und dann immer wieder das nächste nehmen
und wieder rein drücken sondern entsteht
eine art kleines musste
nämlich einen pizza blech und zwar habe
ich hier diese perforierten pizza bleche
denn darin back die pizza auch wirklich
sehr knusprig und ihr braucht noch
keinen backpapier sondern es geht
einfach ein bisschen olivenöl mit den
händen drauf streichen
man kommt da die calzone drauf und wer
möchte kann noch mal ein bisschen
betroffen
er wird alles hier sitzen gefüllt und
verschlossen und die kommen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 250 grad ober
unterhitze da müssen sie jetzt etwa 20
minuten backen
und die kids mag ich ganz gerne weil sie
außen knusprig ist also dieser pizzateig
knusprig und innen hat man diese saftige
füllung macht durch immer weitere ich
schick dir schon mal in ofen okay super
bis bereit morath die pizza calzone ist
fertig kann töne als 100 aber wenn die
euch nicht appetit macht dann eigentlich
gar nicht weil ich finde ich super
genial und lecker aus wir bekommen ja
genau
aber dies ist natürlich noch ein
bisschen zu heiß ich lasse jetzt etwa
fünf minuten abkühlen damit sie noch 100
grad heiß ist und ihr könnt übrigens
statt normalem weizenmehl was ich
verwende könnt ihr natürlich auch
dinkelmehl benutzen
dann nehmt ihr am besten 630 dinkelmehl
und ja lasst uns kurz abkühlen und dann
schneiden wir die monotone auf töne
moreira intel der mora david probieren
einen teller
ja du kannst ruhig alles gibt dass ich
einmal koren bleibe also ich muss dieses
projekt du benimmst einfach in die hand
und essens aus der harmonie das ist ein
riesen charakter viele kindes von früher
ich musste es aus schweinebrück wirken
ging nicht kennen es gar nicht
es ist immer noch warm jetzt müssen mehr
käse ein bisschen mehr zu machen ja also
man kann gerne noch etwas mehr erfüllung
nehmen und ich finde es so schön wie dem
ofen aufgehen so richtig hübsch und
kommt um englisch ist wie so ein döner
das visum döner in der tasche denn die
frau von einem kran genau richtig lag
ja also ich hoffe dass sie jetzt auch
appetit bekommen habt falls ja dann
findet das rezept nach nachlesen auf
zehn.de da stets noch mal für euch und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachhaken
die zweite ungeduldig denn im sommer
muss zum ballett gelb biete macht es
nach ganz hessen das jetzt hier und wir
machen die ein bisschen was übrig ihr
müsst das ding nach war nicht super
lecker also bis zum nächsten mal
das ist mein stil
umso mehr müssen